Vsauce. Michael here today with a
special video.
It's a Skype conversation I had with Newt
from Underbelly where he teaches me
about six actual villains from real
comic books
that are really, really lame. He's joined
by a bunch of ladies from Underbelly,
and as you will see immediately from
Storytime, he's quite
the ladies man.
First things first, you should know that
I'm kinda busy right now playing the
May update for Angry Birds Rio
and I'm not wearing pants.
So,
we're already up to a really good start.
"Hey, over here.
It can't be," Prince Hobopopo says.
"In the flesh."
If you're gonna read me the bad guys, you
gotta read in the scary voice. You know I
only want you on the show if you do what
I tell you. "In the flesh."
Just be quiet, I wanna do this.
At number 6
we were gonna have Kite-Man, who's a Batman
villain, who's just some
dork with a kite strapped to his back,
but I decided instead
to go with a color-blind villain, because
color blindness is nothing to joke about
in America.
So, I thought I would go with Rainbow
Rider, who is a flash
villain and this guy just sucks, alright?
He basically
has glasses that project colours and
then he create structures for him to
emote from that are colourful, but I mean,
really, this guy's just fabulous. 'Cause
everything
is rainbow colored. Anyway, it's just one of those
characters where it's like four o'clock in
the morning and they're like "oh, we got to
have the Flash fight, somebody."
"I know, we'll have a guy who rides rainbows."
The
next one on the list, number 5,
we have armless
Tiger Man. Basically this guy's story was
he was a small German boy who had his
arms ripped off
in an industrial accident. He went around
during Golden Age Marvel books
using his sharp teeth and his prowess with his toes
to destroy all machines.
Next up on the list we have Crazy
Quilt, who is a Batman villain and this
guy has the most
eye-be-jarringly bad costume in comic book history.
And I think I just made up the word "eye-be-jarring." Crazy Quilt was a low-level
robber who was blinded by a bullet,
but in prison had an experimental
surgery to restore his vision,
but unfortunately the vision that he was
left with was so disorienting
that it drove him crazy. Wow, Vsauce doesn't even have t-shirts and you guys already have
dresses and girls.
We have several... we have home and away uniforms.
Next up on the list we have Egg Fu.
An Egg Fu was a Wonder Woman villain,
who, at the peak of the Red Scare,
would try to have people denounce their
love for the red white and blue
and this worked with him using fear,
because he is essentially a giant
egg with a mustache.
Katie, what do you think about Egg Fu?
It doesn't matter, she's a woman.
Next up from the
freaky deaky seventies,
we have the Hypno-Hustler.
And this guy's clearly... he's got the most glorious
glittering crusted Afro I've seen
on the printed page, it's amazing.
Armed with hypno goggles and...
Oh, one second. Thank you.
Any port in a storm, right?
The ladies keep coming. I have them bring
me drinks every now and again when
I get parched.
Armed with his hypno goggles
and power boots, he put the audience in a trance
and was able to rob them.
His name is
Turner D. Century and he was a Spider Woman
villain and essentially he, he hates
young people
and he wants to restore, restore
San Francisco to the glory days
of like the 1900's.
So he flies around
on a bicycle, okay?
And he goes
toe-to-dandy-toe with any superhero
who tries to stop him.
And he has a horn that's honking fury
will kill anyone under the age of 65
years old.
And that's how he can restore San
Francisco to the glory days.
So that was our top six worst,
my top six super villains
in comic book history. And this is
kicking off, this month is Superhero Month.
We're gonna give you a top 10 worst
superhero list,
so turn up a little bit. Kevin
from Underbelly is going to give us a
little
piece called "Saving Superman."
And then we're gonna introduce a new
Underbelly character and we hope that you
enjoy it. It's gonna be some fantastic stuff
going on this weekend,
just in time for Captain America and the
Green Lantern, all the big
comic book movies coming out this summer.
That is perfect. So yeah, everybody out
there
go over to Underbelly show on YouTube and
be sure you're subscribed
for their unique brand of infotainment,
and, of course, the ladies. In fact, to fit in
better, let me just do this.
Perfect, okay, great.
So,
yeah, go check it out, it's super hero and villain
month over on Underbelly shows.
Subscribe.
And as always,
thanks for watching.